wir sind erstens für eine maximale
humanitäre hilfe in der ukraine und von
hier aus wir sind zweitens für die
lieferung maximale lieferung von waffen
zur verteidigung
wir erlauben uns aber darauf aufmerksam
zu machen dass russland mehrfach sehr
massiv damit gedroht hat dass sie in dem
moment wo wir sozusagen
zur möglichkeit des angriffes beitragen
dass wir dann als kriegspartei
betrachtet werden und wir riskieren eine
eskalation zum atomkrieg die position
die ich vertrete es war viel zu sorgen
dass die ukraine sich so verteidigen
kann weil das bei den verhandlungen die
die ganze zeit stattfinden das da
russland bereit ist echte kompromisse
einzugehen und es ist bisher nicht der
fall der vorschlag ist wir liefern jetzt
nichts mehr an die ukraine die ukraine
wird erobert
noch mehr frauen vergewaltigt noch mehr
zivilisten da kann man noch mehr leute
landen im gefängnis
mein vorschlag ist wir unterstützen die
ukraine weiter dass sie sich wehren kann
wir sorgen für einen für harte
sanktionen
dass russland bereit ist in den
kontinuierlich stattfinden verhandlungen
mit der ukraine endlich einen kompromiss
einzugehen und das was sie vorschlagen
ist dass es einfach ganz besonders schön
weiter geht dass wir so wie putin es
angekündigt hat die demokratisierung der
ukraine hinnehmen nämlich krieg sagt
ihre annahme einfach dass in dem wir
sagen wir wollen halt dass er jetzt
verhandelt das funktioniert nicht herr
hofreiter ich finde sie unterschätzen
dann doch das engagement und die
bemühung dieser politiker tätig der
frühere osteuropa berater von herrn kohl
er hat gerade gesagt der einzige
europäische politiker der noch mit putin
wahrscheinlich hätten könnte wären und
das hat etwas damit zu tun dass es da
eben doch lange einen kontakt gegeben
hat der immerhin 1 gebracht hat frieden
wir hatten den frieden in den regionen
hatten die menschen keinen frieden es
ist langsam an der zeit dass wir unsere
überheblichkeit unsere arroganz ablegen
und den menschen die direkt betroffen
sie zu brauchen ich weiß ihr
emotionales engagement für die menschen
in der ukraine werden also eher
hofreiter es geht nicht an dass sie sich
hier als stellvertreter aller opfer
gerieren nach allem was ich weiß und das
komme hier aus führt sehr weitreichende
kompromisse angeboten plus putin keinen
einzigen kompromiss akzeptiert sondern
nichts anderes verlangt als die
vollständige kapitulation und zerstörung
der ukraine er verlangt die
demokratisierung der ukraine die
zerstörung der kultur und der sprache
und der ukraine und die zwischen die
selbst aufgaben des staates wären
außerdem möchte ich sie bitte darauf
aufmerksam machen dass in wahrheit
verhandelt wird zwischen russland und
amerika
sie haben damals 218 die chefredakteurin
von russia today im gespräch gehabt
haben wir sehr viel raum gegeben und sie
konnte da über die angebliche
überheblichkeit des westens schimpfen
sind sie damals und sind sie jetzt in
dieser sendung dass der vorwurf von
herrn hofreiter der russischen
propaganda der kreml propaganda putin
propaganda essen gesessen also herr
weise ehrlich gesagt ich erinnere mich
gar nicht dran aber die wildschein
besser zu recherchieren als emma ich
will noch einmal auf die perspektive
kurz der opfer aus rein gehen wir selbst
berichten hier seit mehr als zwei
monaten
wahnsinnig intensiv über diesen krieg
vor allen dingen mit unserem reporter
paul ronzheimer der einer der ersten war
dort in butscher der die leichen dort in
den strassen gesehen hat wenige tage
später haben wir auch mit dascha
gesprochen in der süd ost ukraine die
vergewaltigt wurde von raw zwischen
soldaten dort in ihrer stadt die darüber
auskunft gegeben hat weil sie wollte
dass das der westen erfährt frau
schwarzer was sagen sie dieser dascha
zum beispiel könnten sie ihr gegenüber
in angesicht den inhalt ihres briefes
vertreten denn die emma war eine der
ersten die über die gefallen
vergewaltigung in der ukraine berichtet
hat also da sehen sie mich an vorderster
front ich bin ja dafür dass es aufhört
und das ist nicht unnötig lange
weitergeht das ist der unterschied
zwischen uns herr hofreiter das wird
schon er exakt reist zu behaupten sie
sind dafür dass es aufhört und nicht
weitergeht und gewerbe dagegen es ist
mehr als wie dreist ich fürchte dass
dieser briefen beispiel dafür ist dass
wir viel zu wenig mit den menschen
mittel- und osteuropas sprechen und dass
wir viel zu wenig auf die stimmen der
direkt betroffene nach die stimmen der
dritten opfer hören und dass manches
sozusagen
dadurch uns wieder unterstellt wird
welche sind die klassischen arroganten
deutschen die die länder zwischen
deutschland und russland um deren
interessen einfach vergessen